talib et mantallot apprendre à faire
plein de choses mentalement c'est super
bien mais rester concentré pour pouvoir
le faire c'est beaucoup mieux
fin août je suis allé faire la première
partie de verrines en testant un nouveau
numéro est devant les 300 personnes je
me suis retrouvé complètement bloquée
pas durant tout le sketch ce n'était pas
forcément le trac c'est le moment où je
devais rentrer en introspection j'ai pas
réussi à le faire instantanément
j'ai mis trois minutes pour ça c'est
long trois minutes devant 300 personnes
que j'essayais de faire sur scène c'est
quelque chose que j'arrive à faire tout
seul en trois secondes à la maison c'est
pas compliqué la seule chose que j'ai
pas fait ce jour là c'est de me
concentrer avant de monter sur scène de
me concentrer réellement peu importe les
gens peu importe le bruit peu importe
tout le lendemain j'ai refait le même
numéro et il ya eu aucun problème la
seule différence entre les deux jours
c'est que le lendemain j'ai pris
quelques secondes pour me concentrer
avec une vraie méthode de concentration
ça m'a permis de me focaliser sur
l'instant présent et cette méthode de
concentration aujourd'hui je fais un
petit master class pour la partager avec
vous la première chose à faire c'est
d'utiliser une technique de respiration
qui va réduire un petit peu le stress
qui va réduire les pensées négatives
c'est une technique de respiration dont
certains à sophrologie mais y en a plein
d'autres
celle ci elle est très efficace tout
l'exercice vous le faites uniquement par
le nez en fermant bien la bouche tout
d'abord vous allez inspirer à fond à
fond à fond sans chercher à gonfler
levante vous remplissez un maximum vous
remplissez jusqu'à remplir toute la cage
thoracique ça doit prendre au moins
quatre ou cinq secondes et ça va
détendre tout les nerfs de la cage
thoracique ça va réduire un petit peu
toutes les tensions vous garder l'air
pendant deux ou trois secondes au moins
et ensuite vous expirez à fond vraiment
très fort tout par le nez durant cinq ou
six secondes vous cherchez à vider
complètement l'intégralité de vos
poumons vous attaquer ensuite une phase
de repos de deux ou trois secondes c'est
à dire que vous allez recommencer le
processus mais vous n'allez pas inspiré
tout de suite à la fin d'expiration
vous allez inspirer au moment où vous
sentirez que vous avez besoin d'inspirer
vous ne forcez pas la respiration donc
il peut se passer de trois secondes
avant de ré inspiré et vous faites ça
deux trois fois d'affilée à la fin de
cette étape vous serez déjà beaucoup
moins dispersé mentalement et ça vous
aura pris à peine une minute
même un peu moins deuxièmement avant de
commencer la chose importante qui vous
demande de vous concentrer que ce soit
un cours un travail représentation peu
importe ce que c'est que vous avez à
faire éviter les discussions inutiles et
commencez à vous isoler un petit peu
quelques secondes c'est juste pour faire
un espèce de sas entre le futile et le
moment où vous allez devoir être
concentré fait un point mentalement sur
ce que vous avez à faire pourquoi vous
devez être concentré quel est le but de
cette concentration
fermez les yeux quelques
comme s'il n'existait plus que vous et
le but à atteindre via cette
concentration voulait rouvrir go c'est
parti et 3e étapes
la concentration ça passe par la tension
simplement par l'attention
donc vous allez faire un exercice qui
aident à développer son attention plus
vous ferez cet exercice là dans votre
vie plus ce sera facile de vous mettre
dans un état de concentration extrême
très rapidement perso je le fais 1 3
face à peut se faire en plus mais en
trois phases ça va je le fais aussi les
yeux fermés je vous conseille de faire
ça c'est beaucoup mieux pour bien
s'isoler vous allez imaginer de rails de
train qui sont parallèles comme si
devant vous à vos pieds y avait deux
rails de train qui partait loin dans une
plaine parallèle vous regardez bien les
rails de train mentalement quand je dis
vous regardez c'est mentalement ses
rails là et vous essayer de continuer à
visualiser tout en imaginant ce qu'ils
vont faire jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
l'horizon jusqu'à temps qu'ils se
rejoignent en un seul point
prenez le temps de le faire prenez le
temps de bien visualiser ensuite ouvrez
les yeux respirez un bon coup refermé
les yeux et c'est reparti vous allez
dessinée mentalement dans le vide le
symbole de l'infini mais pas avec votre
doigt comme je suis en train de le faire
même si vous pouvez le faire au départ
pour vous aider mais juste mentalement
comme s'il y avait un point lumineux qui
partait quelque part devant vous dans le
noir toujours les yeux fermés et vous
lui faites tracé à ce point lumineux le
symbole de l'infini vous essayez de
repasser dessus de trois quatre cinq
fois jusqu'à temps de bien le voir
devant vous et pour terminer vous
imaginez un tableau devant vous un
tableau effaçable ou un tableau à craie
devant vous et vous aller visualiser
votre main en train d'écrire le mot
mental donc vous écrivez mentale
mentalement sur le tableau une fois que
vous visualisez bien le moment talent
juste à cette fois là alors vous effacer
le elle pour ne voir plus que mental
mais prenez le temps de le faire
toujours faut pas que ça aille vite faut
que vous visualisez bien ce qui se passe
une fois que vous êtes sur deux de bien
voir que mental alors vous allez effacer
le à puis après vous allez effacer le
thé puis le hen plus le jusqu'à temps
que vous fassiez tout et vous savez quoi
vous serez prêt vous serez dans un état
d'attention et de concentration extrême
à ce moment là vous serez beaucoup plus
faux cul sans vous laisser parasiter par
tout ce qui se passe
selon pratique ces exercices plus on
arrive à les faire rapidement - il faut
à peu près une minute trente pour faire
tout ça et je le fais systématiquement
avant de monter sur scène pour mon
spectacle
parce que là je l'avais pas fait
d'ailleurs je joue mon spectacle demain
à la garenne-colombes demain soir et les
autres villes c'est quand tu passes je
vous mets un lien dans le descriptif
vers mon site internet il ya toutes les
dames n'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce
en l'air la vidéo si vous l'avez trop
utile c'est important merci également de
l'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout bien sûr
abonnez-vous avant de partir et rendez
vous demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mandat le blog ciao
[Applaudissements]